مرحبًا ، أنا دانا سانتس مدرب للتنفس
والجسم الذهني في الرياضات الاحترافية ،
هذه المجموعة من التمارين التي أنا على
وشك أن أوضحها لك مصممة لمساعدتك على
إتقان حركات وزن الجسم وهذا أمر
مهم لأن لدينا جميعًا أجسادًا
ونحتاج إلى التحرك من خلالها  جميع مستويات
الحركة وهذا يعني ببساطة المستوى
السهمي الذي يكون للأمام والخلف فقط
وهذا هو المكان الذي نقضي فيه
معظم وقتنا ولكننا سنتحدث أيضًا عن
المستوى الأمامي وهذا جانب إلى جانب
والمستوى العرضي الذي
يدور الآن يمارس هذه
ستساعدك ستة تمارين بمرور الوقت على
بناء قوة الحركة والمتانة ،
فأنت لست بحاجة إلى أي شيء من أجل
ممارسة هذه التمارين ما لم تكن
على سطح صلب وقد تحتاج إلى
حصيرة وإلا فلن تكون هناك حاجة للأوزان أو الدعائم.
ابدأ
بقرفصاء بسيط بوزن الجسم ، فأنت تريد أن تبدأ
بمسافة بين رجليك وورك ،
وبعد ذلك تقوم فقط بجلوس القرفصاء الآن بذل
قصارى جهدك لكسر متوازي وهذا
يعني فقط أن الوركين  ستقع
تحت ركبتيك الآن إذا لم تكن هناك
بعد ، فهذا جيد فقط تعمق بقدر ما
يمكنك بشكل مريح ، سنقوم بإجراء
ثمانية إلى عشرة ممثلين من هذا ، لذلك دعونا نفعل ذلك
معًا في طريق الشهيق
وفي الطريق للأعلى  الزفير هو واحد
اثنان
ثلاثة الآن ، قد تلاحظ أن قدمي
تستمر في السير معي ، قدمي متجهة
للأمام بشكل مستقيم إذا كان
من المريح لك أن تقوم بزاوية قدميك
للخارج ، ولكن فقط تأكد من
أنها بزاوية متساوية ،
لاحظ أيضًا ذلك  أنا أضغط على ركبتي للخارج
لأنني أنزل مما يساعدك على
تنشيط تلك العضلات حقًا ،
واحد آخر
ممتاز في
هذا التمرين التالي يسمى
مفصل الورك أحادي الساق ارفع ساق واحدة وضع
يدك في التجعد الذي تشعر به
ثم تخيل أنك سحبت  منضدة تصل إلى
هذا التجعد وأنت تنحني
بظهر مسطح لطيف الآن إذا شعرت
بالكثير من الشد في أوتار الركبة ،
يمكنك فقط ثني ركبتيك الآن بالطبع
نقوم بذلك على ساق واحدة في كل مرة
لأن  انها مفصل الورك ساق واحدة لذلك
أنت  قم بتحويل وزنك إلى جانب واحد ،
سترفع الرجل المعاكسة ،
ثم تذكر تجعد الورك هذا هنا
بمفصلتك للأمام ،
سنرفع أذرعنا لموازنة تلك الساق خلفنا
، ثم ستعيد نفسك مرة
أخرى بلطف  لمس القدم هناك برفق ،
لذا سنقوم بأداء
ثمانية إلى عشرة ، وسأفعل ثمانية
معك الآن على هذا الجانب الأيمن ، لذلك نتوقف
للأمام
ثم نعود
ثم نتوقف للأمام
ونعود مرة أخرى ، هذا بالتأكيد
سيذهب  لتحدي توازنك
إذا كنت بحاجة إلى مساعدة في التوازن ، يمكنك
دائمًا وضع كرسي بجوارك
أو أن تكون قادرًا على الإمساك بالحائط أثناء
قيامك بهذا ،
لذا
تذكر أننا نريد أن يكون ظهرًا مسطحًا قدر
الإمكان وستلاحظ  حتى أنني أحني
ساقي قليلاً
بحيث يكون ذلك سبعة أضعاف
ثم ثمانية ، لذا دعنا نذهب إلى
الجانب الآخر ونتذكر أننا نريد أن نحول
وزن
أجسامنا على ساقنا ثم حركة المفصلة هذه
لبعض الأشخاص خاصة إذا كنت على
حق-  سلمت
لذلك هذا واحد مي  اكتشف
أن رصيدك يواجه تحديًا أكبر على
الجانب الأيسر
أيضًا ملاحظة واحدة أيضًا
تريد أن تحافظ على رأسك ورقبتك
متماشية مع عمودك الفقري
[موسيقى]
بحيث تكون خمسة
ستة
[موسيقى]
سبعة
أخيرة وتذكر أن الساق الخلفية
لا تحتوي على  لكي تكون مستقيماً ، فقط ابذل
قصارى جهدك للإعداد لهذا ، أريدك
أن توقف وركيك للخلف ولكنك
ستثني ركبتيك حتى تعلق الوركين للخلف
مثل هذه القدمين لا تزالان
متباعدتان عن بعضهما ثم ستضع يديك
خارج ركبتيك الآن ،
يُسمى رفع ذراعك لأنك سترفع
ذراعيك إلى الأعلى
وسنقوم بعمل 10 ممثلين معًا ، هذا
ليس تمرينًا صعبًا حقًا ولكني
أريدك أن تركز على شكلك وماذا
كنت تشعر أنك ستشعر به
في ذراعيك ولكن على وجه الخصوص
أسفل لوحي كتفك مباشرةً عندما
ترفع إلى هذا الموضع ، يجب أن تشعر
ببعض التنشيط ، لذا دعنا نجري 10 ممثلين
معًا ،
لذا هنا
ثم نتراجع
[الموسيقى]
هنا
ثم تراجع
حتى
ثلاثة ولاحظ أن الملكية الفكرية  ause في الجزء العلوي ، لذا
توقف معي أربعة
وخمسة
وستة
لاحظ أيضًا أن راحتي تواجه
بعضهما البعض وأرفع رأسي وأعناق
ثمانية وثمانية إلى أعلى وأعناقها
متماشية مع
بقية العمود الفقري 10
لقد فعلت
هذا التمرين التالي هو دفعة أساسية-  حتى
الآن ، أعلم أن عمليات الدفع يمكن أن تكون صعبة على
الأشخاص الذين لا يمارسونها بشكل
منتظم ، لذا لا تتردد في ترك
ركبتيك إذا كان ذلك أكثر
راحة لك ولكننا سنقوم
بتمرين تمرين العضلة الثلاثية و  هذا يعني أنه بدلاً
من الكوعين
، سنبقي الكوعين مشدودتين حتى نشعر بمزيد
من العضلة ثلاثية الرؤوس في ظهور الذراعين ، لذا
فإننا نقوم من ثماني إلى عشر مرات ،
دعنا نمضي قدمًا ونقوم بثمانية معًا
حتى تقوم بإعداد  في وضع اللوح الخشبي ،
يكون معصميك أسفل
كتفيك مباشرة ، ثم تكون قدميك على مسافة الورك ،
وتأكد من أن
مؤخرتك ليست مرتفعة ، حيث أن قلبك مشغول
ولديك خط طويل لطيف مع الجزء الخلفي
من جسمك رأسك ورقبتك  ابق على
الخط ، فأنا أتطلع للتحدث إليكم من حين
لآخر  بشكل عام ، ها نحن ذا نذهب ، نستنشق نزولًا ثم نخرج زفيرًا ، هذا شهيق
واحد
ينزل
زفيرًا ، ادفع اثنين
ثلاثة ، تذكر أنه يمكنك إبقاء الركبتين
لأسفل إذا كنت بحاجة إلى أربعة
وخمسة دورات ضيقة ستة
سبعة
ثمانية هذا التمرين التالي هو الركوع
t-  لف العمود الفقري حتى تحصل على
الوضع كما لو كنت هنا إذا أمكن
الجلوس على كعبيك ثم
ضع يديك أمام ركبتيك
ثم سنستبدل وضع اليد اليسرى
باليد اليمنى حتى يدي
اليمنى  الآن أمام ركبتي اليسرى
وبعد ذلك ما سنفعله هو أن نأخذ
هذه اليد اليسرى ونرفعها لأعلى
بحيث يكون ذلك تكرارًا واحدًا
سنفعل ثمانية إلى عشرة سأفعل ثمانية معك
لذا هذا  واحد
عندما نستنشق ذلك الزفير لأعلى ، نخرجه
إلى الأسفل ، هذا اثنان ،
لذلك نحن نركز على الدوران من
منتصف ظهرنا ثلاثة
نتبع تلك اليد إلى الوراء أربعة
شهيق كبير ، نعيدها إلى أسفل خمسة
ستة
سبعة
أخير
ثمانية
الآن نفس الشيء  الجانب الآخر لذلك سنقوم
بإعادة اليدين  في الموضع ،
استبدل اليمين باليسار ،
وها نحن نبدأ
واحدًا
اثنين
الآن تظل هذه اليد اليسرى
ثابتة حتى لا تتغير ، وبعد ذلك
يمكنك التحرك أكثر
من أربعة
أضعاف من منتصف ظهرك
مرتين أخريين ، لذلك  هذا هو سبعة
شهيق كبير
ثم تراجع
هذا ثمانية ،
هذا التمرين الأخير عبارة عن لوح جانبي للساعد
وسيتحدى قلبك ،
لذلك سنقوم بإعداده عن طريق
وضع مرفقنا أسفل كتفنا مباشرة ،
وهذا مهم حقًا
لصحة الكتفين
والوركين  تصطف فوق بعضها البعض مثل
هذا ، لذا فإن الكتفين تصطفان فوق
بعضهما البعض أيضًا ، ثم يقوم كل ممثل
برفع جسدك ببساطة ، لذا
سأعرض ممثلًا ، ثم سأوضح لك كيفية
التعديل لذلك سأذهب  للرفع
وهذا زفير بالمناسبة
ثم أعود بنفسي إلى أسفل ،
لذا ستشعر أنه يتحدى قلبك حقًا
إذا كان هذا كثيرًا بالنسبة لك ،
فستثني ركبتك السفلية إلى 90 درجة
ثم ستساعدك ركبتك
دعمك وأنت تأتي حتى جو
على هذا النحو الآن ، سنقوم بثمانية ممثلين على كل
جانب ، لذا قم بالتعديل إذا كنت بحاجة إلى أو
متابعتي في النسخة الكاملة هنا ، نبدأ في
الزفير ثم إلى الأسفل ، بحيث
لا تدع الوركين لأعلى اثنين لجسمك يدور
جيدًا
أربعة
وخمسة
تشعر بأن قلبك يعمل ، يشعر أن تلك
المنحنيات
تحافظ على رأسك ورقبتك متماشية مع
عمودك الفقري
ثم
آخرها وننتقل إلى الجانب الآخر ، لذلك نفس
الإعداد في هذا الجانب إذا قمت
بالتعديل على الجانب الآخر من هذا الجانب
ستحصل  أقوى عندما تتدرب على هذا ،
لذا هنا نخرج زفيرًا للأعلى
ثم نعيده لأسفل حتى
نتذكر ثمانية تكرارات أي اثنان يتذكر الزفير
أي ثلاثة
فخذين يرفعان
خمسة
وثلاثة رأس ورقبة أخرى تماشياً مع
عمودك الفقري لا تسقط ذقنك
ثم آخر مرة
الآن بعد أن خضت جميع
التمارين وأنت تعرف ما يجب أن
تتوقعه ولديك شعور أفضل
بمدى قوتك ومدى نجاحك في
ذلك ، يمكنك أن تقرر ما إذا كنت
تريد تكرارها لجولتين ، ربما
ثلاث جولات أو أربع  جولات في وقت واحد
ثم y  ستجد أنه مع
استمرار التمرين
، ستتحسن بشكل أفضل وأن القيام بذلك
مرتين أو ثلاث مرات في الأسبوع يعد أمرًا مثاليًا
ولكنك لن تؤذي نفسك إذا كنت
تفعل ذلك كل يوم وأنت
منتبه  لتشكيله حتى تقرر ما هو
مناسب لك ويتناسب مع
جدولك الزمني
[موسيقى]